[Music]
Venice's in the end have to find an
agreement on the way forward to address
international situations international
crisis today it was Libya but of course
this doesn't fall out of the sky so we
prepare that with proposals our main
task is getting a consensus amongst
Member States on Libya you know that
this is going to be an agenda item on
the next Foreign Affairs Council
migration and the southern neighborhood
of the two main priorities of the
Maltese presidency when it comes to
external relations there are only three
hundred kilometers away from the Libyan
Shores it's in the interest of everybody
to make sure that's Libya regains its
stability everyone comes from their own
different national setting their own
traditions and their own way of doing
things I think it's also one of the
strengths of the European Union that we
try to find unity in this very diversity
sometimes positions are quite diverse
it's a cumbersome process but once you
have it it's of course a very strong way
of addressing the issue because you
speak in the name of 28 member states
[Music]